Rhodey, I swear to God you make my stupid robots look like skilled Swiss technicians.
Quiet!
Oh! That was my favorite.
Suit up, Rhodey.
This one wants to play tag.
Rhodey. Better late than never.
I left you one.
You're all heart.
Thank God for product placement.
Roxxon appears to be initiating a hostile takeover.
When will the suit be finished?
Roxxon always fulfills its contracts, General Shatalov, to the letter.
And Stark?
Unknown, unknown.
I know what you're looking for...
...and I know where to find it.
Damn! I wouldn't have believed it if I haven't seen it with my own eye.
See? I told you I could do it.
I made her fly, Nicky. I made her fly.
Right.
You're impressed.
I get it.
I understand.
Wanna take it for a spin?
Looks like Shatalov has gone rogue.
Enough gas in this thing to get me to Russia?
Gas? You're so old school, Nicky.
It'll get you where you need to go.
Just be gentle.
Last one home is a loser.